hey guys what's up this is andrew with
transcendences.com
so as you can see i'm not in hong kong
anymore i'm right now
on holidays i'm in xiaomi so this is my
hometown in france
and as promised guys i'm taking some
time for you even during my holidays to
make
an update on amc so let's get into it
[Music]
so guys as usual i'm gonna start on the
first time frame i'm gonna remind you
quickly what i was saying in my previous
video i'm gonna try to make this one
quick just to sum up the information
basically i did my last video using
thursday's close
and so i'm missing friday and monday
session so i'm gonna update you guys
with what happened during those two days
and you're gonna see that we have
some very interesting information so
let's sum up very quickly the situation
here we take a step back
as usual guys so here amc went from 10
guys
to 73. so this is my third wave and as
you know guys i'm using elliott wave
theory
that is saying that moves up developing
five waves so this is a three
very obvious before we had a one two
three we are doing a four and the fifth
is
coming so here what i wanted to show you
guys first in my previous video
i showed you that we can make uh
discounting in two different ways
so i'm not sure exactly which one i'm
gonna keep i like this
one because here i can break down
this price action into five waves quite
clearly inside my triangle here i'm
having
my 52 breakout level that has been
retested once twice
three times and guys very important we
didn't retest it on
friday's session even if the market was
bearish amc lost something like five
percent i was in the plane i was looking
at the chart
i was looking guys at everything that
you were saying on my discord
by the way guys thank you very much for
making it active it's very
interesting to read at everything that
you guys have to say on amc
and i'm gonna be more active on it i'm
gonna try to give you more color
more updates more you know everything
about amc
about gme about everything else that you
guys are interested in the market
so just when i'm gonna be back from
holidays but
basically uh what is interesting guys
here that i wanted to show you
either we do this scenario like i had so
let me show you quickly
the alternative scenario guys is that we
are still in the triangle right
so it's like this has not started yet
not
actually so it's gonna start here okay
and this is just a triangle so this is
the alternative scenario
that is not changing much but here i
struggle to actually count five waves
inside of it but sometimes triangles
have seven or nine waves
so it's possible as well this scenario
is
good as well to use but here you can see
that it's not
fitting perfectly on the downside the
lower band is not retested very clearly
if it was a triangle why we didn't go to
47 48
you see because i think that this
triangle is not what is playing out i
think that the triangle was here
and that's i'm gonna go back to my
previous counting that was giving me
once again a very nice breakout
level at 52 that has been tested once
twice and not the third time
so this is the information that we're
having basically in two days
nothing much happened guys i can see
that you know you're asking yourself
oh yeah is there any update what do you
think about today's press action so
nothing has changed 61 64 at the levels
to break out 61 because here we have
this trend line
when you have this kind of trend lines
against that very important if the
triangle is here or not
if it's the upper band of my triangle
anyways guys when you have a trendline
like this
if we break that this is a very
important level so it's right now
at let me make it perfect
it's even lower it's around 60 61 and
this would be the third wave of my
fifths
one two three and inside the three one
two three so the third
looks like it is extended so 61 is the
level to watch what you guys want to see
is something like this
you know we break out will be test if
here we have strong volumes this is
confirming that 61 is the level to watch
i told you that 64 is the level to watch
they are both levels to watch
64. i'm keeping an eye on this one
because it would mean
if we break 64 that even if you're
having a complex correction
let me show you guys again what are
those complex corrections so
here double and triple three so in the
elliot wave book that you can find on
google
written by frost and pressure at the
page 30 guys
have a look at that elliot called
sideways combinations of corrective
patterns double threes and triple threes
which are actually the usual corrective
patterns that we see right now
w x y where w x and y
are zigzag flat or triangles and if this
is the case which is possible guys which
is possible then if we trade above
64 which is the top of wave b here in my
abc
it would mean that this whole complex
correction is
over right now you know i'm not sure
maybe it's something that is doing
that is a bit longer in time you know
maybe here we have an abc
maybe the sea wave is like this you know
i'm i can't be
sure right now but what i know is that
if we trend above 64 this is off the
table all right
so what are our different scenarios not
here first the information i wanted to
give you guys
very very important that happened on
friday we had
some very very precious information here
look what i want to show you guys
market making higher lows in a
bearish environment so the magdee is
doing what guys
magdie on the fourth time frame is
making
lower lows because we are correcting
still you know we are maybe stealing
this full sweat and if we're not we're
on the second wave of the
fifth wave so in both cases we are in a
corrective environment
on the short term on the hourly of
forest and frame but still the market is
making
higher lows because there are so many
investors so many buyers that are more
aggressive than just sitting at the 52
level
the right train to do right now as i
told you guys in my previous video is to
build up some long position you know
buying the 51 52 53 levels
you know if you are a sculptor you can
use a stop loss around like 50 you know
something like this
because if we break 51 what would happen
is that here we would probably have a
flat
all right this is the alternative
scenario that we have in here
a big flat right something like this
this is possible as well
if we break 52 but guys we are having
a bullish hidden divergence it's this
one let me show you again
this one guys buddhist hidden divergence
in the
when you are in the corrective
environment when the market is you know
correcting
usually the magnet is going lower the
rsi is going lower the casting is going
lower basically we're losing momentum
but the market is actually not able to
make a new low
this is a bullish hidden divergence
right it's this one market making higher
lows
when the magnet is going lower this is
telling us that the bulls are
in control guys in the bare environment
so this is what we just had on friday so
this is confirming
that actually booze and control in this
fourth wave
and it's confirming that the fifth wave
is coming guys
once again i like to count the who
won how many battle all right and here
we were like you know after the third
wave i can't hear the days it was nine
to seven for the bears
now it's like you know the bears won one
day the bulls won another day so we are
back at the same level
but we are having a bullish hidden
divergence for us
on top of what we had before it's now 10
to 8 for the best but look at the
volumes guys
who won the most important day who lost
money here
the bears lost money we came back at the
same level but more
trades were done during monday's session
so it means that bears you know it's ten
to eight
but it's you know the best lost money in
the past two days because once again
the days with the more volumes are won
by the bulls
and this is good and we're having a
bullish hit individuals on top of that
so guys nothing much to say a part of
that i'm confirming that the fifth wave
is coming i give it maybe
you know one more week guys you know one
more week because then
either we break 52 and then we do
an abc it would take maybe two or three
more weeks but if we don't
break 52 on the downside then we need to
break on the upside the 61 level and
probably the 64 level is going to be the
domino effect
that we saw before stop losses of
bears are going to be in this area
around the 61.64
level then they're going to retreat guys
retreat you know because they know
they're losing they're not
getting hammered and they're gonna just
pull back the orders
at safer levels they're still gonna be
there guys they're still gonna be there
they're still gonna accumulate some
short positions
and they're still gonna lose money i
believe that
so guys that's it for me i just made it
short you know i just want to sum up the
situation
of what happened in the past few days
and once again you know we came back to
the same level but with more confidence
so this is looking very good for me so i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys